it really is a bit like the weather
actually is miserable absolutely
miserable here today and that is the
mood of workers of course facing at
least months of on certainty thousands
of jobs at risk for body a is Northern
Ireland's largest manufacturer I think
it's five percent of the entire
manufacturing base of Northern Ireland
so it's not surprised that there is at
concern one man who knows by that it's
Stephen Kelly he's the chief executive
of manufacturing Northern Ireland you
represents aerospace and indeed some of
those companies that supply the plant
here what is the mood and the reflection
on that decision made overnight
I think the first I view would be that
people are stunned by the decision by
the yes Commerce Department even Boeing
themselves are only looking at an eighty
percent tariff the Commerce Department
is gone even further
essentially troubling the price of the
CSeries aircraft so the first one was
stung the second issue is the
termination to actually get on and make
sure that this case is fought a lot of
efforts gonna move the politicians a lot
of efforts going in here locally and
across the world as well and we're also
very hopeful lastly to try to make sure
that this is overturned because frankly
this is a nonsense decision this is an
example of protectionism that is of days
gone by we live in a more integrated
free trade word world
and what we need nice to make sure that
these jobs are protected do you think
though president troubles talk about
puttin American jobs first gonna listen
to Theresa Bay why would he do that well
he needs to listen because the the
reality is that more than 50% of the
CSeries aircraft is actually
manufactured in the United States itself
whether that be the Pratt & Whitney
engines or other components there's a
huge amount of American jobs at stake to
make sure that this decision is
overturned
so why stirs uncertainly now at the
moment we would be hopeful that come the
spring time the International Trade
Council will actually turn around and
reverse this decision would you like
local politicians and indeed the British
government to take I think we've all
been impressed by Prime Minister Trudeau
when he turned Ryan and he told Boeing
in particular that if your plan on tea
damaged the Canadian economy and the
Canadian companies then you can sing on
if you want to try to get any of our
work on any of our business we certainly
believe the UK government should be
stepping up now you to basically stare
down this threat to make every effort
they can with presence
Trump and his colleagues in this cabinet
to make sure that these jobs here in
Belfast as well as the jobs in the
nether states are actually protected
Stephen thank you very much Stephen
Kelly there for manufacturing Northern
Ireland chief executive off I think also
either way and there is a little bit of
optimism that this is simply a
preliminary decision that ultimately all
that pressure all that lobbying by the
UK government and indeed others may well
weigh down and the decision may be
reversed we wouldn't expect a final
decision in February of next year all
right Aaron thanks for that get back
under your umbrella now what does the
Bombardier decision tell us about the
UK's chances of a quick comprehensive
trade deal with the US where I'm joined
now by Britain's former ambassador to
Washington Sir Christopher Mayer so what
are your conclusions from this well I
actually don't think he's got a wider
significance beyond this dispute itself
Bombardier is a very small minnow it
hardly competes with Boeing at all the
CSeries jet is roughly comparable with
the 737 and boeing has a very long track
record of trying to whack people who
appear as competitors in the aviation
market in the thirty year war if I can
put it that way with Airbus is testimony
to that does it have a significance
beyond all of this for a possible
free-trade agreement between us and the
Americans after brexit I would say no
this is this is a self-contained
Aviation Department of Commerce problem
a lot of people will say would this be
happening if Donald Trump were not
president well it could well be
happening because I'll tell you why
Boeing is one of the most powerful
companies in the United States of
America its lobbying power in Washington
DC is quite extraordinary it has fingers
in all kinds of pies it has
manufacturing and in factoring
facilities all over the United States
which guarantees it a good solid base of
senators and congressmen who will always
support them so this is what we the
British they the Canadians and
Bombardier the company have got to deal
with right I won't repeat what you said
about the international trade commission
just before we came off on there but
it's
to say in your opinion that this is a
very pro-american body indeed and has
been thirdly well so the Department of
Commerce which has now rendered the
initial judgement is my experience has
always been a highly nationalist
protectionist body and the sector for
commerce has been appointed by Donald
Trump and it may be that in all of this
because Bombardier is fundamentally
Canadian owned there's some kind of
NAFTA the North American Free Trade
Agreement message while the US the
Canadians the Mexicans discussed the
future of the of this free trade
agreement so that there could be that
there but the default position of the
Department of Commerce is to be tough
for weather 220 percent increase in
tariffs even by historical sounds pretty
high the hopes are vested in as your
report was saying in February when the
International Trade Commission meets to
consider the partner commerce judgment
has it in his power to overturn it to
maintain it or to reduce the tariff
level now that body is ostensibly
independent bipartisan and not subject
to political pressure it has a boss a
very good woman called Rhonda slickline
who was appointed by President Obama and
she I suspect his holy house of sympathy
with the ideology of of the Trump
government but we can't bet the house
that the ITC the International Trade
Commission will actually mitigate this
decision now Michael Fallon has so far
said that he's not going to start
withholding defense contracts against
Boeing do you think he should do well
the British government's been a rock and
a hard place here because Boeing itself
has a very large footprint in the United
Kingdom it has a much larger footprint
in the United Kingdom than does
Bombardier I know it's really tough for
Northern Ireland but directly and
indirectly you can say there are between
twelve and fifteen thousand people whose
jobs depend on the work given them by
Boeing so if we pop up and say wait
we're going to whack you guys if this
goes on we
shoot ourselves in the foot so it's a
difficult place to be so Christopher may
appreciate your insight sir thanks for
joining me